it's not that difficult
really to step out of the stream of
thinking
to um
one way of course is meditation it's a
traditional approach is
you have certain periods of time once or
twice a day when you sit down
close your eyes
and instead of involuntarily
being drawn into the continuous stream
of thinking
you usually in with meditation you have
a technique or method
you focus your attention on one thing
which could be a mantra
that you preach it could be
your breathing
it's a very ancient meditation it could
be the inner feeling in your body the
sense of aliveness that pervades
pervades your body in other words you
take attention
away from thinking and that's already a
great realization that you are able you
have a actually have a choice of
directing attention you don't have to go
to you don't have to go with your
attention all the time where the
habitual thought patterns want you to go
the habitual thought returns want your
attention every time every thought says
i'm attack give me your attention follow
me they go this way and another negative
thought and another one and another one
there is a source of power in you that
transcends the person
and it's not egoic power over somebody
and it's one with a power that
is the power of life in the universe
where all life arises
and
people sometimes have a problem with
self-confidence
or
valuing yourself
and
sometimes
you try to convince yourself by changing
your thinking that
you are actually good enough
that you should be self-confident
but there is a better way
to find
the source of self-confidence
on the egoic level self-confidence is
there because you see you can tell
yourself
i'm actually more intelligent than most
of these people
or
i'm better looking than most i have to
remind myself that i'm better looking
than most and then okay yeah i feel a
bit more confident now
or you say i actually have more money
than these people so i should i
have more self-confidence
whatever it is some way of convincing
yourself and then you compare yourself
with others
and then you focus in
on those areas where you feel superior
to others and try not to think about
other areas where inevitably you are
inferior to others because you cannot be
superior in all areas
it's a complicated game when you start
start comparing yourself to other people
and if you want to bolster your
self-confidence and you only have to
focus on where you feel i'm actually
better than most but that doesn't really
work that well
so
there is a better way of self-confidence
that is nothing to do with comparing
yourself with others
or with feeling you are better than or
not as good as
and that is direct access
to inner power
you don't need any comparison
you can
have it right now at this very moment
if you're not stuck in your thinking
mind
but take your attention a little bit
beyond the thinking mind
and then realize
that you are
the presence behind the thinking mind
without which there could be no thinking
you're the aware presence behind it all
that that is deeper you've gone deeper
than the thinking mind and that aware
presence
is
where power
resides
and it's not yours
because it connects you with universal
power
therefore
you don't need to compare yourself to
anybody anymore
or feel as the ego always does
that you are either superior or inferior
to somebody else
that's a not a comfortable way to live
where you have to classify yourself when
you meet people
and so you if the fear is always
i might be inferior
or
behind that fear is a desire to be
superior
many people spend their lives in a state
of
almost
permanent
dissatisfaction right unfortunately
so
they may be looking for some purpose or
they may have given up hope that there
is some purpose for them and they're
just surviving
or making a living or caught up in the
doing caught up in the doing in the
stress of it right and so
usually when we talk about a purpose
when people talk about purpose they
think of purpose in terms of
future where am i going what am i
supposed to do
what's the direction i'm going what is
my goal the goal that i want to achieve
and that of course
is there it has its place but i call
that the outer purpose
more fundamental than the outer purpose
is what most people usually overlook
and that is the realization that
what matters most is finding your inner
purpose
so
inner purpose is aligning your life
fully
with
the present moment
so that you are no longer out of
alignment with the present moment which
leads to the state of dissatisfaction
that we talked about that is the reality
for many people
so you have to go first of all beyond
the state of dissatisfaction that is so
many people's reality right but you
cannot go beyond the state of
dissatisfaction through some future goal
that says one day i would like to be in
a state of fulfillment or satisfaction
no you have to
enter the state of fulfillment and
satisfaction by becoming one internally
with the present moment and your purpose
and your inner purpose is
that alignment
with where you are right now to be
totally where you are and whatever you
are doing
even if it doesn't look like you're the
life purpose for that you want for the
next 30 years right whatever you are
doing now to be total in doing it and no
matter what it is to be true to life by
being true to this moment i need my
story
all the things that my i've been telling
myself in my mind about myself and other
people and my parents
and my relatives and my co-workers and
my ex-wife and my ex-husband
and what people did to me and on what or
what i did and shouldn't have done
failed to do
[Music]
am i without the i can't let go of that
i need to think about this more
so it becomes a habitual place the
habitual place of the of
the mental noise where you feel that's
me
and so as every therapist knows
that you always reach a point with your
clients patients whatever depending on
the school of therapy depends whatever
you call the your clients your patients
whatever
there comes a point when you hit that
resistance
they don't want to be free of their
problems
and that the big challenge is there
is this person going to overcome
that barrier
because that barrier is not just
becoming free of my problems
but also
becoming free of a very
limited
and ultimately fictitious sense of
identity
the me
so that is
what i've
described is
the next
step one could say in the evolution of
human consciousness
is
stepping out of
self-talk which is
the conditioned mind
and realizing there is much more
to who i am
than this conditioned content of my mind
and that
is the beginning of awakening it's not
it's not those words not not that you
need to believe that there is much more
to who i am than the self-talk in my
head because that is still
self-talk in the head
i believe there's more to who i am
and you better believe it too we may be
surprised to know that there are
millions
billions of people on the planet who
have that same thought pattern there's
something wrong with me
it's part of the human ego
but so you bring in the awareness
and that
will change
everything
that's the only true
key
if you fail
next time you the anger arises
what happens you will become aware
immediately after the anger has subsided
and then with oh there it was and i
wasn't present
and then the
that
the moment will come when you are there
in the first if you can catch the anger
the first moment it comes
or if you might even see that it could
be the result of a thought
that creates the anger and if you can be
there in the first moment because before
it becomes the fully blown
anger then you can stay there and it
might not even become fully blown anger
if you catch it the first moment you can
feel the first doesn't matter
and so you be thankful for your anger
because
the anger can become a very important
spiritual practice for you
because through it
awareness can grow
so it's it's a sometimes strange for
people to see you can be thankful for
things that you think are
the most difficult obstacles in your
life
but they become
they can become your greatest
opportunity for for spiritual awakening
use it
as part of your practice many people
have this idea i want to achieve
something great great or be somebody
great
and they neglect
the step that leads to greatness they
don't honor this step at this moment
because they have this idea of some
future moment where they're going to be
great right some people believe i'm
doing great work i mean i am because the
consciousness is moving through this
form i don't feel personally responsible
for what i do as such
but even there
it is small steps when the writing
happens there's a notepad and a pen
unless the present moment and there's a
stillness very small there's not some
idea i'm going to create a work that's
going to change everybody's
consciousness no i'm just
true to this moment what is this moment
requires it's a blank piece of sheet of
paper
and a pen
and a stillness
it's a small thing
it's all a sequence of very small
moments
and by being true to this small moment
something great arises talking about
past and future and excessive
emphasis on past and future in your life
yes of course you need to have
there's nothing wrong with having a
certain
intention of what you want to achieve
take steps towards it it's part of
living here in this dimension you can't
just say i'm never going to plan
anything anymore just take life as it
comes well some people try to do that
but they're not that happy either after
a while
so then your life will get very diffused
and so to have an intention to have to
make a plan perfectly fine what either
short-term plan like i'm going to meet
you tomorrow at 4 o'clock
how would you ever meet anybody if we
didn't have time
and
and future in a practical level of
course it's needed the question is
whether future takes over your mind
being able to use it for practical
purposes is of course great but
i call that
clock time is fine
but psychological time is when the
future takes over your mind and your
entire thought patterns are geared only
towards future and you treat the present
moment
as either just a means to an end because
enables you to get to the next one
you're always reaching out so to speak
internally to the next yet never quite
here always looking for some fulfillment
there so you can never embrace the
fullness of now
or you make them now into even an enemy
some people are always unhappy
you perhaps we all know some
one or two people like that three
we who are wherever they are they are
they're complaining it's never quite
right wherever they are or whoever they
are with after a little while they're
very uncomfortable again it should be
somewhere else
you know the bumper sticker that you see
in some cars in the various versions of
it says i'd rather be golfing and then
another one says i'd rather be fishing
i'd rather be this i'd rather be there
when i visited the the spiritual teacher
ram das who lives in hawaii
he has a bumper sticker on ram das was
the person who in the 70s wrote the book
be here now
that and anyway he has a bumper sticker
on his car that says i'd rather be here
now
so
so and and then you realize you can
actually
you can still pursue
whatever an intention where you want to
get to a plan
i call that it's a bit like a journey
your life is a journey you're going you
know you want to go from here to there
whether you're going to get there we
don't know maybe on the way you'll
branch out to somewhere else but at
least you have a certain direction it's
good to have some direction in your life
but while you are traveling
if the
your destination takes up most of your
attention and you're continuously
focusing on there you miss all the
journey really you can't enjoy the
journey anymore and most of your life is
the journey the arriving is relatively
rare the wedding
and the fuel
graduation but so those moments are not
the fine view between so the rest is the
journey and if you can't enjoy the
journey which means the step you're
taking at this moment
is really the most important thing yes
of course you know you're going that way
but this step is still to be enjoyed
because that's ultimately your whole
life consists of the step you're taking
at this moment there is never anything
else if you think the world is full of
evil people you will meet many evil
people
and
in other words unconscious people and
even people who are on the brink or who
are halfway been constantly unconscious
when you come together with them your
belief will pull them into
unconsciousness
and that's karma
so karma is
the complete absence of
conscious presence and so it's it's
automatic it plays itself out
and time does not free you of karma that
is a
misperception that if you only spend
enough time eventually
you can become free of karma kama
reduce itself and repeats itself but
it's it's a wheel
and so
the only thing that can free you of
karma is the arising of presence and
why how is it that for
some person presence right i don't i
cannot tell you why
i only know that
at any point
in the wheel of karma presence can come
in it can happen to
this it can happen to a criminal in
prison condemned to death
it can happen to
somebody who's never heard of anything
spiritual
it can happen to somebody who's been
meditating for 30 years or not happened
to some same person who has been
meditating for 30 years
so
in your own life i can see from what
you're saying that presence has already
i can sense that
presence has already come into your life
[Music]
and presence frees you
from karma not all at once
karma has an enormous momentum meaning
the patterns in yourself the thought
patterns the emotional patterns the
reactive patterns
there's enormous momentum behind that
but as presence arises
gradually
karma diminishes
in the energy behind it diminishes
and gradually you experience
a
fading out
of those patterns they become weaker
you're no longer completely in the grip
of those patterns
so as presence arises
there's a gradual fading out of karma
not that it matters that much anymore
because once
you are present
you can
as we the
previous question i said
when
we were talking about certain thoughts
still arising certain negative thoughts
that's still part of the karma the old
patterns the unconscious habit patterns
inherited
they still arise
but it's no longer
problematic and
they no longer cause
the suffering that they would have
caused before because
they are
seen in the light of awareness
so the light of awareness arises and in
the light of awareness the patterns no
longer dominate your life they no longer
run your life
and if occasionally it happens that the
patterns do take over then
after a little while you
presence returns and say oh well there
it was again pain body is part of karma
which may be strong in some people not
so strong in others
and so as presence arises you are freed
from
karma it has
and then you have another completely
different factor coming into your life
and so for example for a person
to become free of collective karma
you need a considerable amount of
presence for that to come in to remove
and it then will remove you in one way
or another
either internally you find yourself
completely free you might still live in
a violent society but internally you
would be free there is such a is a
possibility you can have a holy man or
woman
living surrounded by violence it's
possible
it's rare but possible
or very often it happens that life
removes you
out of there and you find yourself
somewhere else
so
let's say vast
collective karma for example
in the case of
let's say
you have the taliban there you have
uh
all kinds of unconscious movements you
had
soviet communism you had national
socialism in germany and for a person
being born into that
and not being drawn into that
unconsciousness requires considerable
presence
so not that many people for example in
germany when hitler came to power
not many people were able to remove
themselves somewhere
some artists some writers
they they left they could see what was
happening and they they they were strong
enough not to be identified with the
collective
when there had been a tradition of
obedience to authority for hundreds of
years a tradition of following your
leader and so on
to
to take yourself out of that collective
karma requires considerable presence but
some people had it
so
it is our destiny then to
go beyond karma by
being the
receptacles for presence
all you can do
to be helpful in this world and help
others
is
those people that you come into contact
with
[Music]
you may everybody in this
with
awakening will find that
sooner or later they become a kind of
teacher
to others and what a spiritual teacher
does the teacher points out the
possibility of awakening out of
identification with unconscious patterns
which means the spiritual teacher
teaches you to
go beyond
karma
if you want some bob proctor
affirmations for success check out the
video right there next to me i think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
i'll see you there how many times have
you had somebody say to you hey have you
got a minute but
you got a minute
they don't want a minute
i want you to think about that